greetings from coronaville you bad
[ __ ]
it's monday the 23rd of march
the church is brought to you by one of
my favorite
undies in the world me undies me undies
me undies me undies
as a podcast fan you've heard me and
other schmucks with microphone blab
about these bras
boxes and briefs for years but here's
the thing
meundies is the world's softest most
sustainable
[ __ ] underpants you can put on it's
like having an angel cradling your nuts
all day every day while you're rocking
miami undies listen if you open up my
uh little [ __ ] draw underwear it's
all me undies that's all i wear is me
undies i love me on these
i live by me on these i don't give a
[ __ ] what they tell you yesterday i went
outside i hit the bag was it hot
yesterday
i have no idea you don't know he stayed
in my backyard i went out there
the sun was so [ __ ] hot i was
sweating i went in later on
the the band around my stomach was sweat
it was a little wet
but my balls were completely dry why
because my undies
that material that that it's it it keeps
the moisture out of your nuts you can
smell your nuts at nine o'clock at night
and they're still fresh
listen do me a favor go to the undies
right now
me undies will not stop till every
single one of you
tries them so meundies has a great offer
for the church family you ready
any first-time purchases you get 15 off
and free shipping it's a no-brainer
especially because they have
100 satisfaction guarantee or your money
back that's it
to get your 15 off with your first pair
free shipping
and 100 satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com
joey that's meundies.com
joey it's monday and we got [ __ ]
things are bad
we're all trying to stay above float
kick this [ __ ] mule lee
oh [ __ ] it all starts [ __ ] today all
right no more [ __ ] excuses this is
the year
of the [ __ ] soldier we're going in
like [ __ ] marines
[Music]
[Music]
myself the christ killer
and myself i don't want to [ __ ] bring
it in
or give it up
what's happening you bad [ __ ] i
know it's been a rough week for a lot of
you guys and my
heart goes out to you it's been a roller
coaster of emotion because nobody knows
what the [ __ ] is really going on all i
know is i think jews are spreading it
because
yesterday it's [ __ ] saturday i'm
walking around i'm driving around
just to see the climate you know i'm
living like [ __ ] mad max
and i see all these [ __ ] jews walking
in clumps down
uh chandler boulevard i know there's a
temple but the temple's [ __ ] closed
why are you never watching why are you
walking around on saturday floor
and clunks with little yarmulkes on and
[ __ ] like six or seven of them talking
about the stock market
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you listen
we're living in a time now then
i know we're all diehards walt world
die-hard [ __ ]
i've been in since march 2nd yeah you
think i want to be in someone is that
what you [ __ ] guys think
is that what you really think that i i
don't want to go outside marching but
we had to play this hand up am i scared
am i
listen i'm not [ __ ] scared but i am
scared i'm scared because i have friends
i have family members i'm myself i'm
[ __ ] old
and as you can tell i've been smoking
weed for [ __ ] 30 40 [ __ ] years
so i got the beginnings of eczema
whatever the [ __ ] that is
not eczema emphysema emphysema eczema
that's the skin thing that you got all
over the [ __ ] place
but i got it too don't feel bad
uh i got everything i got a [ __ ] up
toenail i got everything what's corona
going to do to you bud
the whole [ __ ] thing is you got to be
careful you got to be vigilant
you know all week long governor newsome
is doing a great job in california i
don't know
if you guys know who he is or whatever i
usually don't like politicians but at
least he's keeping you informed
and he's telling you that you gotta
[ __ ] stay in
you know i'm stocked up on everything
you know i got stocked up way before
like i was telling lee for years i've
been telling my wife
we live in an earthquake zone what does
that mean what does that mean that you
always got to be prepared for the next
day i got a generator
i bought a generator about two years ago
because i got sleep apnea there's an
earthquake we lose the power
and i've always told my wife to buy two
of the essentials
what's essential screen corn just buy
two extra cans every week
when you go on and buy a jeff peanut
butter whatever the [ __ ] you buy get an
extra one yeah when you go in and buy
soap get an extra soap in my garage
i have it looks like a little
supermarket
it's professionally like a [ __ ]
little thing
and it's peanut butters and pastas you
think i [ __ ] like ragu
no but times like this you need rag
you know little things you know i don't
go to the supermarkets i don't let my
wife go to the supermarkets
you know on one hand they're telling you
social distancing and on the other hand
you're in a supermarket
i would only go to the supermarket if i
went early in the morning
your odds are less the earlier the
better because less people have been in
there
you know you go to the park any park you
go to now
governor newsom said yesterday he hasn't
seen so many people are running
everybody's rocky balboa drive down the
street that's all you see is people
running now especially in california
there's a park a couple miles from my
house called noho park there
it's on magnolia and [ __ ] my
hunger hunger i go there from time to
time
i smoke a joint outside i get a little
vitamin d
i was even telling steve simone for
years i would go over there and swing
kettlebells
and wait till it gets really hot and i
pick a tree with shade
and it's the best workout you could do
because you go for a walk to warm up
then you go to your car it's got i think
it's two
walks around the circle is a mile wow so
you walk once around the circle
then you go to your car and i would go
to a tree that had a shade
and i would do kettlebell exercises and
[ __ ]
uh you know swings and cleans and squats
and then i would do like
i would just stretch but if it got too
hot i went under the shade
what i did the swings i made sure and
did them in the sun
so i would get my sweat would give me a
natural suntan
it was [ __ ] tremendous it's a great
bark but now you go to the smoke pot and
yeah people are staying there social
distancing
but they're all running in the same
direction
so if i'm running behind you even if i'm
10 feet behind you
i'm going to eventually catch what
you're breathing because this stays in
your particles this stays alive in the
air
for three hours in your part in the
[ __ ] air whatever the [ __ ] so
these are the things that we're not
doing we're doing a lot of things right
a lot of things wrong you know me i
don't give a [ __ ] i'm minding my
business yeah
if you need a [ __ ] coffee from
starbucks go [ __ ] yourself okay
i got coffees from all over the [ __ ]
world at my house bustelo
la yave i got espresso from italy
i got the [ __ ] courage machine you
know if you really really gonna
need you need to [ __ ] at least wear
gloves when you get the cup and spray it
down with lysol
i got mini light saws i got [ __ ]
large lysols
check this [ __ ] out no matter where i go
i'll [ __ ] lysol you right in the
[ __ ] eye
lysol has become the new mace you
understand me
i mean so just take care of yourself you
know it makes me laugh
i saw those kids at the beach and [ __ ]
oh my god they showed that dirty white
kid with the pink cheeks
you know we go to school all year we we
listen you get bees i can tell just by
looking at you
you're a d type of [ __ ] you
don't deserve nothing but
i gotta tell you something guys i gotta
be honest with you who the [ __ ] am i to
judge those kids
who the [ __ ] are you to judge those kids
every single one of us
would have been out when we were 21
right now not giving a [ __ ]
i was talking to a dear friend of mine
last night she's like a [ __ ] doctor
we were laughing on the phone i go she
goes and these kids are gonna knock it
off with the [ __ ] kids
knocking off with the kids you and i
both know that when we were 21 we'd be
beating the door down at joe mary's
right now
snorting the corona rivas we would have
been snorting like
can you get in powder form yeah bring it
to us we want to just snort it so
i i don't get mad at those kids i feel
bad
you know that's there before the grace
of god go i you know
uh it's tough to sell it to a kid it's
weird
i hear like be like this this one comic
i know was posted on facebook that
her roommate tried to bring a like a
booty call over
she said no like a lot of people like i
i assume people are going to be on
tinder and
everything from what i hear most people
aren't really they got off tinder
i mean yeah you have to just be
careful that's it that's all they're
asking you to do
i left here last [ __ ] week i came
over here with mercy for something
maybe sunday or something we came over
here cleaning the office
we just wanted to take a ride i wanted
to give her mother a break
and i told you i went by the federal i
mean they're talking about it
the federal was packed it's a borrower
lancashire
across the street from the whatever
theater what's the name of that data
running
no the other one the the portal theater
oh it's so funny how they [ __ ] uh
it was packed and the thing that killed
me the most was there was
people with their kids sitting in boots
and there was a bunch of fingerprints on
the glass
as soon as i see fingerprints on the
glass i stop eating at your place
that's it it's over you know
now the stress part of this thing a lot
of you guys
are [ __ ] stressed out i know it i
know you're stressed out
you're thinking about when it's gonna
end listen let me give you the best
advice
i can give you nobody knows nothing
i got an email this morning from a
friend of mine
she's closing the gym until the 18th and
she feels bad and i you know
we went back and forth listen there's
nothing you could do
until the 8th to the 20th nothing
and don't think like people calling
already like hey
the 20 listen nothing's going to be the
same for a while
this isn't just going to go away on the
18th the reason why they did this was to
shut the curve down
so this week right now is going to be
crucial this next week you can't crack
this week
and the week after that you can't crack
the week after that you'll see some
daylight you yes you'll see some
daylight
what they're doing this for is so look
what's happening in italy
and i didn't know i couldn't figure it
out
until my wife was talking to me and she
goes in italy all the families live
together it's like new jersey
your grandma lives on the bottom floor
your mother lives in the medium floor
and you and your wife live upstairs and
you do everything together
you eat together you have groups
together look at the fusco family god
bless their soul out of free home new
jersey
four people died in the family no
because they kept they had a party the
other day
my heart goes out to them they're just a
family that that's tight that loves
hanging out there i was supposed to go
home in april for my like
75th anniversary party that's cancer
yeah they canceled it already canceled
that's canceled because all those
weddings and everything have old people
yeah existing conditions so the big
thing for me that it showed
us like how not in control we are like
we
like we act like we're in control of our
daily lives nobody
and this is what we're going to talk
about today that you
do have they listen they they broke it
down for you so now you got two things
to say you got two things to do you
could either [ __ ] cry
go into a [ __ ] depression or do
something about it okay you got three
options you could go into a funk
that which leads into a depression which
leads into sickness and worry and
whatever
or you could take this by the [ __ ]
horns okay listen man
i'm not gonna lie to you the week before
the seventh at ufc when romero
i had a nervous breakdown that night i
was supposed to go to a dear friend of
mine's house to watch the fight
and i had like the beginnings of a
[ __ ] stroke okay i could feel my neck
tightening up
and i got in my [ __ ] car and i went
down there against my
bully you know because i was scared i
was scared of having contact there was
there was gonna be other people there
you know what i knew that i called them
up beforehand
and i said there's any of these people
that are over your house traveling
and he goes nah they're all agents from
the office i said [ __ ] it i'll come down
and i went down there and i for a couple
days i was apprehensive before i had to
go to new york i was very scared
and then the confusion started you know
you start hearing about your work
getting canceled
and you're losing dates and you're
losing money guess what
everybody's going to lose money not just
you this isn't a plan against you
this isn't [ __ ] somebody deeming you
you did not do anything wrong
lee didn't do anything wrong i didn't do
anything wrong
this happened when things like this
happened you got three [ __ ]
what did i tell you guys last week that
i felt like [ __ ]
you know how i felt i felt exactly how i
felt after my mother died
and i felt exactly how i felt after i
got a divorce
what does that mean that means i'm
mourning a loss
we lost the ability to live the way we
have been
living for the last 100 years now
if you don't think there's gonna be a
fall i love these people that have
rescheduled their toys
like you poor people gonna come up with
[ __ ] tour money
right after this thing is over you guys
are gonna get back to work but for right
now i don't want you to get into a funk
listen you lost your job do me a favor
right now
turn off the [ __ ] podcast you lose
your job
you lose your [ __ ] job and you can
and you are going to lose your family
and your money
before you start panicking get up off
your ass
go to the supermarket any every
supermarket in your area is hiring night
right now
night [ __ ] loaders unloading trucks
stocking shelves you can't uber go to
the supermarket i'm telling you right
now
i'm telling you right now i stock
shelves for years
you smoke a joint you put your little
[ __ ] mask on
and you put your [ __ ] ipod on and you
listen to podcasts and music all night
the first couple nights you drink
mountain dew you sleep in the daytime
you get used to it it's better than
dealing with customers anyways
yes it's better than sitting there
crying
that's my point it's better than sitting
there crying about how you're losing
money everybody's going to lose money
everybody's going to lose money it's the
way life is you know the road got taken
from me that that's
a huge but am i do you see me depressed
do you see me crying have i been angry
no i accepted it because my health your
health
is more important than a dollar listen
unless you're a [ __ ] bum your
landlord's
not going to throw you out unless you've
been a bum for the last year
your landlord is not going to throw you
out if you've paid the rent on time
for the whole time you've lived there
without any problems you you got no
problems
people are going to be sympathetic
listen cable tv
they're a bunch of scumbags they're
going to keep sending bills and if you
can't pay that
[ __ ] disconnect disconnect and go to
netflix for 8.95 a month
that's it yeah that's it you're going to
have to learn to cut
things out of your life that you we were
doing that you're going to see that you
can live without
it's like going away watches i always
say when you go to weight watchers
you used to go to the deli what do you
used to do at the deli
you used to get the 12 foot the 12 inch
with the two sides
the chips and a can of [ __ ] soda but
once you go to weight watchers you
learn that you can live off six inch
sandwich
one side which is maybe roasted peppers
which isn't gonna [ __ ] kill you and
you drink a diet soda
and you got the same [ __ ] meal
without the excess that that that's
always watches teaches you this is what
this lifestyle's going to teach you
guys we've been living [ __ ] heavy for
the last year
we've been living heavy for the last 10
[ __ ] years
250 for this this guy wants 113
a ticket the lakers want 145 a ticket
this is gonna slow the things the [ __ ]
down a little bit
you know now you're gonna have to
[ __ ] encourage people what do you
think happens after this beating that
we're about to get the next two months
we're going to go out in the streets and
jump up and down like it's [ __ ] new
orleans out of [ __ ] whatever no
this is going to take time to heal you
know i'm concerned with the wait staff
at the comedy store i'm concerned with
friends of mine who i know that are
hustling [ __ ] comics that are out
there
taking whatever feature act mc work
whatever the [ __ ] you got
they're going to be hurting right now
and i and i feel for those guys
and in time we'll figure out a solution
for those guys especially
dear friends of mine you know but for
right now
i want you to eliminate that from your
mind because that's going to take you
down right there
there's nothing you could do and a
little bit of money you have right now
if you buy a pound of cheese you better
eat that pound of cheese
yeah if you buy a pound of ham you
better eat that pound of ham if you
if you you know whatever you buy you
better it's got to be worth it it's like
if you throw a punch
you're going to kill the [ __ ]
hour you ain't going to knock them out
or the [ __ ] slap them
it's the same thing with what you're
doing in your life now you know
uh it's a long day
i have a child she's going through
a hard [ __ ] time you know yesterday
she had a good day it's day to day
does she understand what's happening she
understands that she's a little scared
she's a little scared i took it to the
park the other day it was just her and i
playing with the ball
and she's got allergies and she sneezed
and then she sneezed again and she came
up to me and she goes dad do i have the
corona virus
jesus and i go no you have allergies hon
it's a big difference but even then i
took it to the park at 9 00 am
this park is [ __ ] huge guys
i didn't take it to noho i took it to
this other park
for kids up in sherman oaks usually
[ __ ] pretty empty
i found it through a miracle i didn't
let it touch the swings you're not
allowed to touch the swings or no metal
unless you wipe them down and
i took it to this park i mean her we
bought we brought a badminton
set and we brought a wiffle ball in the
back
and we went to the little league field
and there was mud there so i put her
outside the cage
and i set a little target up you know
for strikes and stuff and we play like a
little
whatever stick ball like puerto rican
stink ball like very
no running bases just you know striking
around
[ __ ] throwing curveballs at i'm terrible
at it
but the point being
do you know how many people tried to
walk in between her and my game after
about a half hour
for what reason like
i was seven feet from her
and people were trying and i and i look
at people
and you know and it was all you could
see the people were not
they weren't phi beta kappas you know
this white chick with like an immigrant
camp
he was just excited to be with her so he
didn't give a [ __ ]
he knows they can't make him they take
him back to iraq iran
if he stands next to his white chick
they can't take him back
so he was standing his clothes and he
had a look of
a [ __ ] fear in his eyes like
immigration was going to come get him oh
it was hilarious and they kept walking
and finally a guy walked
and i tell you i i looked at a guy
with his two kids and his wife and his
parents
they were walking the path and i'm in
the middle of the park with my daughter
playing with the ball
it's about 9 30 quarter 10 in the
morning i just want to
leave this is thursday all right now
thursday is quarantines they're still i
haven't seen you all week
no okay so it's thursday the whole world
knows about the corona virus it's
instilled in your brain
you're not gonna believe this when i
tell you guys this is the funniest thing
that happened to me
i'm throwing with the world and i see
this family walking
now at this time uh
you know no matter what's going on i
don't want you to look at people and
think oh he's got the corona virus
humanity is still number one
i want you to say hello i want you to
smile at people
because believe me a wink is as good as
a knot to a blind horse
there's a lot of people walking around
that need hugs right now trust me i
needed a couple hugs a couple weeks ago
uh you know the quarantine then they
take your restaurants from me i can't go
to sushi
you can't [ __ ] take sushi to go it's
like tasty eating
sushi to go no it's melting and [ __ ]
it's like [ __ ] ice cream i don't know
what happens to the rice melts
they throw like voodoo japanese voodoo
or something on the rice
you know it's bad enough with quarantine
we can't go to our favorite restaurants
or whatever all that [ __ ] but
you got to smile you got to be
optimistic
you gotta you know you do the best of
what you can
but you're in the park i'm in the
[ __ ] park minding my own business i'm
throwing
and i'm you know as people walk by or
kids
on the bicycle now they're all 40 50
feet from me
so i'm good i got lysol wipes
you know if you've noticed i wear
different hoodies every day
every time i go home i wash the hoodie
anything i wear does not go into the
house
it goes into a hamper and i change right
in the garage
and we throw the clothes into the
[ __ ] thing
which we're working it straight up so
i'm playing with a ball and i see this
family now the whole morning
i'm saying hello good morning
how are you i'm smiling at people i'm
winking at people they're winking back
finally this family like a wife a
mom you know a husband a wife a couple
kids
and their grandparents and their parents
let's just say
the the couple's parents are walking
and the guy makes eye contact with me
and i go good morning hi
and my daughter says something they kind
of giggle they're like oh how cute
look at he's playing with the ball and
the guy i hear the guy go to the wife
hey that's joey diaz i don't know and i
keep throwing
and i said i feel stress
and i look and the guy's walking towards
me he comes up lee
20 feet and he goes i don't want any
problems i just want to shake your hand
and go
no no
and he looked no means no like his
little heart broke and i go
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you can't be
shaking hands or nothing
go come on you know i love you have a
good day his little heart broke
but he walked up to me goes i just want
to shake your hand
i go what news have you been [ __ ]
watching
uh go no
and i felt so bad even mercy looked at
me like
is that guy is there something wrong
with him dad i go i don't know mercy
when a seven-year-old questions and
adults [ __ ] thinking
that's when you know you have a [ __ ]
problem oh my god
so here's the thing guys i'm gonna give
you the [ __ ] situation
because i thought about it the other day
before i got into this with you guys
you the reason why i'm doing so well
throughout this whole thing
even though i'm getting my head handed
to me and everything else is because
i've been to prison it's like gay guys
you think gay guys are at home scared
are you [ __ ] kidding me gay guys
don't give a [ __ ] they already went
through the hiv
and herpes they got sore throats every
day gay people
you know they don't give a [ __ ] there's
a gay bar that was still open they had a
[ __ ] ticket
yeah they had a ticket the other day
gays don't give a [ __ ]
they're like they canceled the parade
that you [ __ ] the day year already
you [ __ ] up their year already they've
been having hips for years the corona
they just nodded
it's just a thought throat who needs
your lungs anyway you know what i'm
saying
we do what we do but
prison is is it teaches you how to
kill time in your mind and not not to be
bored
and for the first couple days i was
running around with a chicken without a
head you know but i went back to my
prison days
and you have to use what you have
and you have to schedule it you're still
living on a schedule
the tv is not allowed to go on in my
house
until five o'clock well there's no tv
allowed i don't want that plan in the
morning going into your psyche
making it worse than what it is so
there's no morning news
there's no nothing if there's an
earthquake you'll feel it
as we before i went to bed last night
there was a corona virus that's all i
know
the only reason why i don't even turn on
the real news at five
but the tv is not lined up till five me
and my wife made a rule for
all three of us wow all right no tv
till five which really means six
because i watch the six o'clock news and
then i watch world news tonight
and by seven i'm [ __ ] pickles
already now i'm scared all over again
so what you need to do is is is is just
you gotta break up your day and like
you know uh divorces are going up
they're going to go up after this
you have to give people that personal
space
i can tell my wife is starting to lose
in some aspects
you know but i'm also been giving her my
personal space we don't have a big house
but i'll sit in that office entertained
i have a lot of work to do in that
office
so this week what did i do i wanted to
start my mind off
on the right thing so before i even
wrote in the journal
i read a chapter in the art of war again
every day again i've read that book how
many times
but let's state the truth you know let's
talk about resistance again
and let's talk about all those things
because right now you're not looking at
this
as a break you're looking at this as an
opportunity to heal
and go out there stronger heal
and go out there [ __ ] stronger you
know i've thought about this for the
last and smart second i've been thinking
about this what's next
who knows what's this listen forget
about all that
when your construction site is going to
open again whatever the [ __ ] you're
doing is going to open
they'll contact you you're open until
then there's nothing you could do
there's no sense of calling them up and
driving them crazy and
and i know we all got bills and
everything but it looks like it's time
you're gonna get on the call
on the phone and make deals with people
with your car payment people
let them know what's going on just let
everybody around you know what's going
on
just sit down one day for three hours
and call everybody and say look
i figured out my budget and what i could
do
and instead of sending you 280 i could
send you 140.
ain't nobody going to say no to you
this time right now ain't nobody gonna
say no to you guys trust what i'm
telling you
you're giving them a little something
you're giving them a little something
you know
if you can't pay the rent but you give
them a quarter it's better than
not giving them nothing also think about
them
you're broke but also think about them
so if you over 400 and you don't have
the four but you show up with a one
ain't nobody gonna be mad at you you
know what i'm saying ain't nobody gonna
be mad at you everybody
knows right now what's going on
so that's the most important thing
stress will lower your [ __ ] immune
system and you'll [ __ ] catch this
thing anyway
all this [ __ ] if you if you let it get
to your mind
it'll break you down you guys know what
i'm talking about a lot of you guys
have to hit me up and told me you suffer
from depression
if you're already prone to depression
this will spin
you out of control i'm not prone to
depression
and there's been days this week where
this has spun me out of control
why did i stop you know you guys know i
usually work out four days a week
what i had to do with in this time
period to survive
was make my shortcuts my workouts
shorter
so i can make sure i do them every day
okay so instead of working out for 40
minutes
or 45 minutes eat i cut it down
i've been doing 15 minute chunks every
day
just so i don't really kill myself i
still do the kettlebells twice a week
thursday i did a boxing workout and i
mixed it with yoga
just to get the breathing going to get
some of the [ __ ] alley some of the
tension out of me
just the breathing you know the the cat
pose
uh the child pose the [ __ ] whatever
that that
when you stretch out your arms and you
bend your knees
just to get all the joints going but the
most important thing why i did that was
the breathing i wanted to breathe
slowly and then at the end believe it or
not i actually sat down
indian leg you know crawl whatever
indian pose
if this alarm keeps going i'm going to
go out there and break this [ __ ]
windshield
in a second this [ __ ] i'm trying
to keep the door open so we get some
oxygen in here so
if lee's got it he don't give it to me
and if i got it i don't give it to leave
we gotta think about this
we probably won't have guests for a few
weeks we were supposed to have a guest
on wednesday or whatever
i think i'm going to cut the guests out
for a few weeks but
back to that i did that workout routine
and i got to tell you something
i feel a lot better why because i'm
relieving stress a little bit
my shoulders aren't as hard i can't lie
to you guys
i think tuesday or monday i was hitting
the bag at one point
and i thought i was gonna [ __ ] have a
heart attack
just from all the thoughts of what's
going to happen
or going through my mind i don't know
i'm a little bit different for me
like a lot of my depression or anxiety
comes from
there's other i should be doing this
there's more everyone else is doing
better than me
this and that this like something like
this where you live i literally have no
control over it
i had a little trouble sleeping the
first first week
but other than that like i kind of feel
like it like kind of sort of freed me up
like i've done some things that i've
been meaning to do for
years this is about that's what this is
all about
this is all about knowing that your life
is not gonna be how it used to be
drop that idea drop that notion it's all
going to change
and it doesn't take a [ __ ] houdini to
tell you if this goes
to the mandatory shutdown until
april 20th okay wow
mandatory shutdown it's [ __ ] the 23rd
of march we still have another close to
a month
without doing anything guys so yes i
want you to listen to podcasts
yes i want you to [ __ ] exercise yes i
want you to read
books yes i want you to write yes if
you're working from home
yes i yeah you know listen if it's
between you being on the phone with
unemployment
for two hours and waiting do me a favor
let's knock the [ __ ] off grab your
[ __ ] balls and like i said earlier
go to any [ __ ] supermarket chain
right now they're hiring put a mask on
if you're really
[ __ ] broke listen when i'm looking
things go bad for me
i gotta push a kilo of coke even though
i don't do coke i gotta push a kilo or
coke
that's just the way life is i've kept
all my options open
you know i gotta push [ __ ] uh
ten thousand pounds of weed we'll do it
if things get bad and i gotta ship weed
to the
to new york and [ __ ] edibles i'll get
on that [ __ ]
i'll get on that gray i'll put lee on
the greyhound bus you know
i mean and i don't have kids obviously
but even though this is scary and all
that
is there a part of you that is like
thankful for this time to get this time
with her
for like a month on an uninterrupted
me to be honest with you guys as soon as
this happened
i wanted something like this to happen
but not for people to lose their lives
right
we needed a wake-up call
and a lot of people knew something was
about to happen
we just didn't expect this
okay we did not expect this to happen
uh i'm scared for my daughter yeah i'm
scared for it but if you have kids right
now
i know you're worried about them i know
that if you have three
pieces of rice you'll give your kid two
and you'll eat one
you know when you have kids
all bets are off you know lee
i know you want to be an actor but go
[ __ ] your mother
go over the [ __ ] rops and apply for a
job load
this is what this calls for you know
this is when
life becomes life this is like when my
mother died
yeah i i know i want to be this and this
and this but it's too late
you can't play basketball no more you
can't do this
you have to quit school you got to
support yourself you're not getting
social security
this is what needs to be done what you
want is great yeah
i'm thinking of going to stony brook
college who gives a [ __ ]
we can't afford stony brook college we
could afford
uh north hollywood community college
that we could afford so what do you want
to do right you want to cry or you want
to take what's what's available to you
there's no there's no time for crying
now there's no time for [ __ ] fun and
games
you know i feel for you i feel for you
but at the other hand you have to feel
for you too
claim responsibility and go you know
what joey's right i can't [ __ ] sit
here all day i'll go do this
i'll go do this spread your day out i
mean to the [ __ ] hour if you come to
my house now
i've got my little daily notebook to the
hour
to the hour from monday to friday now we
have home school
wow but i did it differently
i take her at 8 45 and i take her for a
walk around the neighborhood
i take it to the corner of the park and
i let her go [ __ ] crazy
you know i take it for like an hour walk
45 minute walk
just to get all that into gr tv when i
drop her off at school today she doesn't
go into class at 8.
they play for 15 20 minutes to get their
[ __ ] yayas out
and to talk i'm boring to her i'm an old
[ __ ] man she doesn't want to talk to
me
but she can't talk to her kids her
friends right so what we've done is
we've set up three of her good friends
we know their mother and i'll call the
father and they'll facetime
oh smart let's go for a walk i'll
facetime
little girls and about another she'll
tell me dad i'm bored
and she'll give me the phone and then
and then we go home
and then i hand her over to her mother
and at 10 o'clock she's got a computer
thing
with the with one teacher
and then that ends at like 10 30 and
then she has a snack
and then 11 o'clock she's got another
one with her main class teacher and all
the students
so for an hour she's yelling you you go
to my house
we put her outside we put her we have
the back room i have yeah
i could have converted into a podcast
studio we turned that into a classroom
oh interesting with a little board so my
wife's got her desk and they could do
work together
so while my wife is doing her work she's
doing her work sitting right next to her
then at 12 we take a breather we eat
lunch and she could [ __ ] uh
watch the computer anything on the
computer for a half hour we eat
and after that we do math then at about
two i bring out the sparring mitts
and she's either gotta do [ __ ] and hit
the mitts
for 15 20 minutes you know so every day
we got to doing something
uh i have it doing the podcast on
tuesday my wife had
had a planting trees you really got to
keep them engaged
because there was a couple days i saw
that week so it took a couple days to
come up with this
yeah of course it was like three days of
like [ __ ] we were all over the place
then we said no let's put her in the
back shut off all the focus
so now she's happy she's adjusting are
there kids
in her school whose parents are both
working right now
they're working but they're working from
home okay
like the main parent she has one
girlfriend that a mother is a nurse
so i'm hearing everything that's going
on in the hospitals through her
wow
what i was thinking a lot about this
week was how you talk about keeping
everything
low like i've been wanting to do like a
two-bedroom oh i want a dog i want this
and that
and this this this week has made me like
thankful that i
keep everything low nothing this is what
i've been telling people for you
just by the house right now for 23 years
i know people who bought houses right
now and have their homes up for sale
they moved into the house before their
home was up for sale
so i know a couple people in that
position
they're [ __ ] who woke up yesterday and
said you know what i think i'm going to
buy a house right now during the season
so the [ __ ] you know i'm gonna walk
into a [ __ ] stranger's house so
you know things are going to change
for a long time as long as you can
accept them
and you're prepared for these changes
but it's the mental that's got to be
tough
it's the men and trust hey guys every
day
i'm not going to want to have a little
bit of a nervous breakdown
at some point of the day i got to reach
for something believe it or not and lee
knows
i have been cutting my weed intake down
drastically i've been going from 20 bong
hits
to six wow five
i don't get up no more and smoke weed
right away
i try to save it for after lunch time if
i could push it till three
the other day i went all the way till
five you know this affects smokers and
vapor smokers
so you have to do all the like listen
guys we're all gonna [ __ ] die
i don't want you to think that yeah
nobody's [ __ ] immortal we're all
gonna [ __ ] punch the ticket but
all i'm trying to do is stay healthy to
provide for my family to see a little
girl [ __ ] grow up
if i can make a high school graduation
i'll leave this planet
happy as [ __ ] and give her the education
and give her the street education she
deserves
and i could turn her into the savage
that she's supposed to be
not to fall for all this stupidity and
jumping up and down and spring break and
following the masses i've done my job as
a dad
and that's all i want to do i don't
listen i don't want to be on tv
i don't want to be [ __ ] famous i
don't want to be kevin hart
i just want to do two podcasts a week
get on the road when i can i don't want
to [ __ ]
have a bus i don't want the traveling
bingo tour
i don't want nothing i just want to make
you guys laugh
be happy and see my daughter grow up at
this point
you know i don't want to be [ __ ]
seinfeld
i don't want to do nothing as far as i'm
concerned the entertainment industry you
know
i really wanted to sit down with you
guys and
once a week or twice a week and maybe do
joey's cabaret
and do stand-up for you guys until i
watched
this week with john oliver he didn't
have a live audience
it was [ __ ] brutal oh really it was
brutal
this is why after you kept calling me
and going what are we going to have
yet tomorrow that is brutal and then
everybody started doing it so now i
wouldn't be special that's true to sit
here in front of a wall and just
i'm not going to charge people right
because i decided
i just wanted to give stand up a break
right and
that's actually something i wanted to
say i'm just i'm thankful that we're
still doing this
just like well not really when i called
you the other day and i'm like sunday
like sunday didn't you see gavin newsom
i i almost
did not i did not say that you said
yes you did i don't know about something
else this is the perfect situation for
you to be quarantined because you've
been quiet
i do like being quick since paula left
you've been quarantined
so this does nothing this doesn't change
your outfit i didn't say it
but but i'm glad that i get to get
another house a couple days a week oh
yeah you do
right you want the west hills for
groceries you could have gone to
and tell me i'm gonna work with smart
i'm gonna tell you people something
i'm gonna tell you people something and
i've told you before
but i'm gonna tell you again i'm gonna
tell you where you
definitely will get corona and the
strain
is the worst one you'll get do not
go to 7-eleven do not go to 7-eleven
do me a favor when you go for a ride
today go to your nearest 7-eleven
and just sit outside the center don't
even go in the parking spot
oh no even if you pull your car
you need special [ __ ] army tanks to
go on the 7-eleven parking lot
the corona virus that's that [ __ ]
that's that [ __ ] uh
that that that that uh isis corona virus
that's different
did you see isis told their militants
not to come back
no that's the funniest line of the week
that's how you know corona is real isis
told its militants to stay
put and do jihad wherever the [ __ ]
they're at
don't come back here and bring your
[ __ ] hive from home don't bring
don't come back with your little hummus
see [ __ ] hollered fingers
back to this [ __ ] plantation that
we're stabbing the neck
we'll put a hood on and chop your
[ __ ] head off
isis told its followers not to come back
that's how serious corona is
[ __ ] so if you want to keep [ __ ]
around and breathing on people
and by the way when i did that podcast
last week and i talked about that girl
that i grew up with that went to all
those loser bars i had
three girls from my youth contact me
that i have not heard from and said
you were talking about this particular
girl weren't you she's a [ __ ] stiffer
right that's how crazy it is
it's it's guys all i wanted to come on
here today is tell you listen
it's a lot worse in your head than what
it really is
i want you to look out for yourself
don't let nobody
you don't want no hand breathing on you
when i say that i don't say
chinese i'm not being [ __ ] racist
i say i mean any wuhan breath i don't
want on me
wuhan breath is [ __ ] corona that's
what wuham breath is okay so when i said
that
it had nothing to do i'm smarter than
that i am not blaming this on the asians
i'm not blaming this
this is a punishment from god to check
us
this is karma checking us this was a
karma check for all of us
we've all been going a little bit over
out of our heads the last couple
years we're not doing the right things
you know it and i know it that we have
not
been doing the right things there is no
reason why we should be paying
400.60 to park
to go see the stones or any other
[ __ ] band
there's no reason why we should be
paying 25
to an already inflated [ __ ] airline
ticket
when you know there's no reason you know
that disney loses six billion dollars
you know what disney
suck my [ __ ] dick you've been
charging 140 to go into that place
for [ __ ] ever now you're dying suck
my dick you were living high on the hog
all these [ __ ] were living high
on the hog dog i grew up in [ __ ] neck
games
nick games i'm sorry i went to nick
games i went to [ __ ] yankee i won the
mech games i went to concerts ten
dollars
now the cheapest [ __ ] laker game is a
hundred and
two hundred dollars the cheapest laker
ticket is 190 there's still the [ __ ]
air conditioner
with a bunch of runaways and [ __ ] that's
what you're trying to [ __ ] tell me
since day one i've been talking about
this podcast about the abuse on the
american family how a family of four
cannot even afford to [ __ ] go on a
vacation anymore
because they rob you at every [ __ ]
length
so disney lost six million dollars go
[ __ ] yourself
you can't even bring water into the park
so they could charge you seven dollars
for that [ __ ] water
seven [ __ ] dollars the movie theater
for a [ __ ]
why should it cost me 50 [ __ ] dollars
to go to a goddamn movie theater seven
dollars for a [ __ ] soda guys
last time i checked i'm an econ mage
it's [ __ ] a nickel
for the syrup and the cup and they're
charging you
seven [ __ ] dollars that's a 300
000 [ __ ] markup so you know what [ __ ]
the movie theaters
[ __ ] amc [ __ ] regal
[ __ ] all these [ __ ] that have
been taking our money for the last 10
years
and laughing in our face you [ __ ] pay
phone call
go check out your [ __ ] bill check you
take an uber take an uber and look at
the taxes
that you pay uber tax getting into the
car tax
uh [ __ ] breathing air tax that you
want everybody's got your [ __ ] money
in your pocket
[ __ ] them now if they're crying
something to go [ __ ] themselves
for years they've been having it with
our [ __ ] money you beat
lee did we not have a conversation here
last year and talk about chris you going
home for christmas
and how expensive it was and [ __ ]
that it'd be american family
so [ __ ] them the airlines are crying now
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] american airlines was at their
highest [ __ ] peak
in 2010 they were charging month they
made 7.6 billion [ __ ] dollars
and instead of [ __ ] making the plane
better they went to
war with their pilots and stewardesses
they yanked all the screens off that tv
they [ __ ] took a bathroom out of the
plane to put more seats in there
on top of the 25 for your luggage they
were charging you
and i got to feel bad for them [ __ ] them
i feel bad for you guys
and i hope this opened up your eyes you
know
10 years ago we were all coming cables
high well now we got hulu
zulu hbo plus showtime plus
but [ __ ] so now you pay more for
[ __ ] cable
look at me i got hulu yeah but you're
paying eight
[ __ ] times the amount you stupid
[ __ ] look at me i got who
yeah i got hula who gives a [ __ ]
now you're crying now what are you gonna
do
and it's not your fault guys it's not
your fault
it's they all tried to [ __ ] us sixty
dollars to park for an event to go to a
ufc fight or this
or that and then to add
insult to injury to add insult to injury
the nfl who owns sundays
the nfl is more popular than the church
from august 15th to february 3rd
the nfl is [ __ ] all we know
ncaa basketball are you [ __ ] kidding
me
it's the [ __ ] pulse of this country
americans
especially in the sec acc
all those divisions they don't know what
to do in march with
you know [ __ ] major league baseball
major league baseball created this
[ __ ] country we
it's baseball apple pie i mean this is
as american as can be
all of them [ __ ] tapped out but then
you got
johnny greed over here still khabib was
going to fight [ __ ] whatever
you know i mean then he has the fights
and he don't show up
he had a fight in brazil i don't see you
there when you show up and you're out
there breathing with these poor
brazilians
then you [ __ ] call the fight then you
could stay at the [ __ ] fight
yeah can you believe this [ __ ] he still
wants to have people out there wrestling
and fighting they're telling you
basketball players got the [ __ ]
coronavirus
and johnny ufc so we're still gonna have
to fight listen i feel bad for khabib
i want to see khabib and that dude fight
to the [ __ ] end i i
i'm dying to [ __ ] see that fight like
anybody else if you're a fan of [ __ ]
mma
that's the only thing on your mind that
you should be counting off the days
i called it when this happened at this
and once they [ __ ]
said that six of the nets had it are you
kidding me you can't have an event there
then when they said that one not gonna
he didn't then they had to talk them
into cancel the next three
did you watch that ufc last week you
know no
it was like [ __ ] a goatsville it was
five people breathing on each other
you know i cannot believe the [ __ ]
greed of some people and this is what
i'm saying
yeah i i listen i want to see that fight
more than anybody but i don't want
nobody getting corroded virus
how would you feel dana if somebody got
the coronavirus whether it be a camera
guy
a [ __ ] the the ref one of the [ __ ]
people that's sitting around the side i
don't [ __ ] know they had like maybe
12 people in
there you know you're exchanging bodily
sweats
on top of that to train for a fight you
have to go to a gym and be around people
everything leads to a sickness and this
guy's still saying the fight's still
gonna go on
and that just shows you where we're at
we don't listen man
oh the day after the [ __ ] thing was
announced
agents were still calling so when are we
gonna put are you
you can't be this [ __ ] stupid you
can't be this [ __ ] stupid
i know people who reschedule dates then
not have to reschedule them again
i told you just to cancel everything the
only date i'm really looking at right
now
is july 31st and august 1. san diego
and vegas and do i expect full houses
not in a million years
i don't expect full houses i'm hoping
the store
the store and everything is open by june
i'm hoping to do brea
june 4th but are you going to come to
the show are you going to sit in the
front row
i'm known as a spitter anyway you know
when i was a kid people used to tell me
constantly hey give me the news not the
weather
i got like a tooth that makes the spit
come out of my [ __ ] mouth directly
how many times i've sat i've been doing
comedy and i spit on people
right by mistakes by mistake you're
talking you see a piece of [ __ ] roast
beef coming out or something
you ate a piece of pizza in between
shows you know what do you think i got
dental floss in my pocket now i started
bringing it after
you know you start headlining a couple
of years and you see a piece of saliva
fly out of your mouth
i don't want nobody in the front row
when i'm performing
so it's going to be very interesting i
don't want somebody to come to my show
so i'd rather not do stand up to
whatever
to the original room just to build my
immune system up
do the belly room just to get i wrote a
few jokes this week
nothing extreme like i said my focus
hasn't been on that
my focus has been but real quick before
we get the podcast going
i want to thank my man david schuler
david schuler put together that opening
track for us that was great
that is [ __ ] phenomenal we could live
with it you know we don't have to play
any
i mean he put he caught the [ __ ]
church of what's happening now
and the vibe all together i want to
thank david schuler
for putting that little [ __ ] rift
together with the church or what's
happening it's beautiful
when i got the call the other day i
didn't know what my friend was talking
about matt
schultz i want to thank him to one of my
agents at caa
who made this all possible but uh
mr schuler i love you i read your
wikipedia
and i'd love to have you on some time
he's a grammy nominee uh award winner
yeah the guy that did this is great i'm
uh and you know
this is what i'm saying right now
this is i'm gonna leave you with this
this is the time to live by this
every day this week i did something to
blow somebody's mind
and friday somebody blew my mind with
this thing with this beautiful
[ __ ] intro for us that he made and
he's got more
don't worry about none he's got more he
told me he could cut this around and
move it however we wanted to do it
so do me a favor no matter how bad you
feel this week
how stressed out you are you want to
feel a little better about yourself i
want you to do me five favors
grab a pen wait do me a couple favors
number one call five people every day
from your phone list five people outside
your regular world
just say hello ask them how they're
doing you know
be human man you know what's going to
beat this loving humanity
i see all these people telling me about
all these bullets that are being sold
i know so we're trying to invoke more
evil with [ __ ] more evil
i'm not saying not to protect yourself
you gotta you have the amendment you
have to carry your [ __ ] weapon
but please don't put your pictures on
facebook and twitter
and put pictures of more guns out to get
people going crazy
i got calls from a friend of mine in
texas he says
you can't even get ammunition people are
getting guns and getting ready for this
listen
i'm prepared you're prepared my whole
neighborhood is prepared remember i
looked two doors down from a retired cop
he's already come over and spoken to me
i put an extra camera in the back
i've done everything i can the alarm is
kicking the
guns are ready but do me a favor don't
put no pictures of guns on
on the internet we're going through
rough times as it is
why do you want to vote evil right now
there's no schools that's a good thing
about this there won't be no school
shootings the rest of the [ __ ] yeah
thanks [ __ ] god at least we got rid
of that situation
we got another different situation now
but don't make it worse
okay you know last time i [ __ ]
checked the with the way to cure vaccine
the way to cure a [ __ ] disease is
through a vaccine it's not shooting
people
so i know why people are getting all the
guns and [ __ ] together listen i
appreciate
that you're using your amendment and
your the right to protect yourself and
all that stuff
but do us a favor don't put that out
there as the front line because
you're really sending out the wrong
message man i got guns too and we got
the grenades and the whole [ __ ] deal
i'm not posting pictures of them up
right now at this time
i want you to call some people i want
you to [ __ ] be mindful of other
people
by the way if somebody hurts an old
person in front of you as a member of
the church
and you [ __ ] them up and you get a
ticket or go to jail
please contact me i will bail you out
personally i will send you the money to
the police department
if you strike someone for attacking an
old person or for
knocking somebody all down in a
supermarket and you kick them in the
stomach and you send me the [ __ ]
paperwork
i will bail you out personally and pay
for your [ __ ] attorney okay
do not let [ __ ] acts of abuse go on
in front of you
if you see a [ __ ] abuse of the
supermarket or anywhere
listen you [ __ ] kick him in the mouth
and you gotta hold the lead you go on
twitter you tell your mom to get on
twitter
tweet joey diaz send me the [ __ ]
paperwork and i will personally send you
the [ __ ] bail money
and i will get you a [ __ ] attorney
that will go in there and say [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
we're still [ __ ] human last time i
checked you don't push nobody you don't
abuse nobody
you see somebody hitting a [ __ ] kid
in the park you [ __ ] knock the [ __ ]
out of it i'll bail you out that's how
we're doing this church okay
do not let all elders get abused in
front of you i've been hearing [ __ ]
people
[ __ ] hitting me up saying they went
to the supermarket no and they saw some
guy push an old lady for a [ __ ] soda
and [ __ ] like that
you see that you got the green light
kick them in the [ __ ] mouth
knock a tooth out start running if they
catch you
i got you
i got you i promise you i got you we
ain't [ __ ] around like that we still
we're still [ __ ] gentlemen
anybody cause i know okey spooky you put
a bullet in your ass oh yeah
yeah yeah hooky spooky's down there in
texas waiting to shoot him she's doing
her own patrols right now
so that's it that's that i didn't mean
to do a podcast today
to scare you [ __ ] i just want
to come and check in with you
remember schedule your day man uh you
know go for walks just don't
you see some guy walking down the street
across the [ __ ] street don't walk
behind nobody you don't want nobody
walking behind you
you know go out get vitamin d very
important for depression
very important very important
you're starting to get stressed out
listen i don't want you to live [ __ ]
wait joey i don't have a gym beautiful
you don't need a gym
all you need is to do slow-motion
push-up sit-ups
go online get some yoga poses and
remember to breathe through them
just stretch you don't remember how to
stretch you know how to [ __ ] stretch
you know how to do push-ups and you know
how to do slips
but i want you to watch your breathing
while you're doing these exercises
because i want you to breathe out the
stress
breathe it out and remember if you can't
nobody's telling you to work out for two
hours you're not fighting nobody in the
ufc
but everything helps yeah that
especially since this thing is a
breathing
disease that boss root and breather
thing is really great
if anyone has breathing issues it really
helps listen i've been living off that
boss room
the o2 trainer trainer i got to the
point where i would walk around the park
with it
but i just felt creepy people looking at
me like what's he doing what's this
[ __ ]
dude doing you said dude on the unicycle
yeah you ever been driving there's a
dude around here has like a unicycle
he thinks he's real cool with his
unicycle i can't wait to see him get hit
by a ups
truck one day i could see it coming it
doesn't take a [ __ ] genius to see it
coming
that he's gonna get hit by a [ __ ] ups
truck like i said i don't know what the
[ __ ] my dates are
as soon as i get him i will let you know
what the [ __ ] they are i hope i could uh
i hope i helped you out as much as i
could today
by doing this podcast listen i don't
know everything
but i'll tell you what i'm doing it's
working for me
there's been no drama in my house
there's been no arguments i love him
more than ever
uh the baby has had her
her moments but i look in her eyes and i
see
what she's going through and it it gets
me a little [ __ ] fired up you know i
give her a hug and i give her a kiss and
uh and that's it guys i wish you
the best i like i said it's easier said
than done joey
give it a shot give it a shot i was
stressed that
the week before i had to go to new york
to shoot that movie
i don't remember myself even being that
stressed out before going to court i
swear to god guys
before getting sentencing i was not that
stressed out
i was really stressed out uh
the week before saint patty's day and
then this week
i figured out a way how to deal with it
uh and yeah i've been eating my edibles
at night
i've been getting [ __ ]
guys the last two weeks i'm not gonna
lie to you i've been going on edible
[ __ ] fox holes
i've been drinking this thing called
quixie 100 milligrams i get it at urban
trees
it's got melatonin in it everything in
it
points you to sleep so i'll take two or
three hundred regular atx
capsules whatever the abx i'll take two
or three hundred of these
first to get the party started i'll
start about five o'clock or one before
dinner
and then i'll pop two more after i take
my blood pressure medication
and then once my wife says she's going
to bed i'll drink that [ __ ]
quick ease quick z and guys
after that ain't no turning back
there really is then they any turning
back i get
[ __ ] up yeah listen to this poor guy
yeah
i get [ __ ] up i ate some mushrooms
this week one night
i just been trying to make the best of
what i have guys so uh
by the way
let's see what we got here oh [ __ ] we
already took the animals
the second half of the podcast is
brought to you by
did you see it did you hear the noise
that's okay that's what you need come
here you go there's a beautiful little
light and these are these tastes great
no
these were grown in a in a
tank look at these worms stop whining
these are beautiful
no no no no stop adding to it right
there that's all you need
that's not even a grand that's a program
we end the podcast off with little
mushrooms here
you know what i'm saying you know how we
do it you know we don't [ __ ] around here
in the church or what's happening now
always a little surprise for you wally
eats his little mushroom cap there
we'll uh talk to you a little bit about
me undies
listen me undies me undies me undies as
a podcast fan i know you guys have heard
me
and every other [ __ ] podcast that
talk about me on these but to me there's
something else
here's the thing meundies is the world's
softest most sustainable underpants
ever it's like having an angel cradle
your little nut sack
all day every day when you're rocking
these [ __ ]
they design their underwear for comfort
and self-expression okay
for me it's the comfort yeah i love the
patterns they're cute i got red ones i
got green ones
they eat the mushrooms i got all
different ones
but the comfort it does i don't like
wearing underwear i don't know if you
people
don't know that when i became a comic it
was either underwear or cocaine
and i picked cocaine so i stopped
wearing underwear now i wear underwear
why
because it doesn't feel like i have
underwear on
that's what me undies has all right it's
time to cut off your toxic relationship
with those tattletale [ __ ] white
things with streak marks and [ __ ]
ball sweat
guys i know you're hoarding some of the
real works of art
in that top draw but make the adult
decision
and get yourself on a monthly plan for
clean
fresh soft skivvies you'll be delighted
with the monthly prints
that they offer for members and you'll
never have to settle for a pair
you'll be embarrassed to get caught in
trust what i'm telling you my me undies
are tremendous don't forget that little
piece there
that little piece will help you out with
the adage of this get me on these
delivered straight to your door
with free shipping they've designed
to be the softest thing you ever put on
your body
thanks to the magic fabric they call
micro modal
i [ __ ] love these things you guys
know i wear them for workouts
i've got them on right now and they come
in all shapes
sizes from extra small to 4x
so everybody's welcome i don't care if
you're skinny
or you're built like me or you're built
like lee
they got me on these for you me and
these just don't make
undies they also have loungewear and all
the same fun patterns
you love in underpants okay listen i
could blow smoke up your ass you guys
have been listening to the church for
years
no i get to choose what i [ __ ] sell i
love me on these comfortable
comfort and they keep your balls
smelling [ __ ] fresh
and that's all that matters to me that's
the bottom line me undies will not stop
till
everybody has at least tried them every
listener
what are you doing he's standing at me
for me so me on these is a great offer
you ready
family grab a pen for any first-time
purchases they're going to give you 15
off and free shipping
that's right free free shipping okay i
know you're going through some hard
times
15 off these are the underwear you need
it's a no-brainer especially because
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee so it's time
right now get 15
off and your first pair with free
shipping and 100
satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com
joey again that's meundies.com
slash joey and i also want to thank me
undies but most importantly
i want to thank you guys for the support
i love you guys
with all my heart i care about you guys
with all my heart thank you for all the
love and support you've given us
we're here for you um listen
i was making videos for you guys
remember that last video i mean last
friday i was [ __ ] up
i blacked out so hard i forgot i made
the videos and the reason why i stopped
i'll start this week once everybody else
stop singing [ __ ] imagine
[ __ ] wonder woman singing imagine and
a bunch of [ __ ] comics putting some
[ __ ] up
when i come to you i want to come to you
like it's original so
i'll do some more periscopes this week
uh
that's it and that's that i love you
guys with all my [ __ ] heart thank you
for tuning in
have a great [ __ ] monday remember to
reschedule your [ __ ]
it's time to start over okay it's just a
little bump in the road
grab your balls and you're gonna be a
better badder [ __ ] than
you were before this whole thing started
have a great day
kick this [ __ ] meal lily
[Music]
you